[Music]
after winning two at home to even the
series the golden knights are back on
the road tonight
game five set to get underway here in
just a little bit sports director chris
matthews landed in denver just a little
while ago chris
everyone here at eight news now is ready
but the question is are you ready
well we are getting ready i'll tell you
what it's going to be an exciting time
the folks in las vegas are thrilled
about this
as we come to you live from denver
they'll be watch parties all over las
vegas
because this is this big one this is
game five of course here at ball arena
boy the avalanche have been one of the
hottest teams in the national hockey
league
especially here at home they've won four
in a row in the postseason go back into
the regular season they've won 13
straight games here at this arena
you go back even further than that into
march they are
20 0 and 1. the only team that come out
of here with points
was the vegas gold knights in that
overtime win so it's going to be
interesting to see you can see behind me
here this place is going to be rocking
10 000 fans will be here some golden
knights fans will be in here
overall this season they were 22 and
four in this play so the avalanche
they too uh they play well at home as do
the golden knights 82 percent of the
games
the abs have won this season they've
outscored their opponents
110 to 54. so they're really really hot
here
but how about the vegas golden knights
they're coming off two straight wins
at the fortress can they make it three
it's always tough they say
to win three games in a row over the
same team
it's hard to beat anybody three games in
a row never mind the colorado avalanche
so
we know the task that's in front of us
and we know their home record and how
good they've been at the same time
i think we have confidence in our game
that that
it'll translate to the road and and
that's our plan
we feel like we've played well the last
two games um we feel like we've done a
lot of good things but again you kind of
have to
hit the reset button obviously we're
coming into their rink it's a tough
place to play so
you want to take the positives
you know and some of those positives
when you think about it the vegas gold
knight scored two goals in this place it
went into overtime they
completely outplayed the abs for those
final two periods and you go back
the last two games in las vegas really
over the last
100 minutes the vegas golden knights
have certainly been
the better team and the avalanche know
that they're going to be fired up the
vegas golden knights have a lot of
confidence
coming up next hour we're going to visit
with a couple of these vegas golden
knight fans who made it out here to the
mile high city once again
so have much more as they get set for
big game five here in denver
reporting live chris matthews 8 sports
now